hallo wir sind heute in unserem büro mit
chelsea und michael wir zeigen euch
heute einen typischen deutschen
büroalltag los geht's
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist michael michael ist heute in
seinem büro michael sitzt am
schreibtisch
er arbeitet am computer
das telefon klingelt michael nimmt den
hörer ab strecke guten tag
er meldet sich mit seinem nachnamen und
einer begrüßung am telefon ist ein
callcenter
michael hat keine zeit für eine umfrage
er wirkt die dame am anderen ende der
leitung ab ich habe jetzt wirklich keine
zeit chelsea arbeitet am schreibtisch
das ist ein loch mit dem lokal kocht man
papier
das ist ein tacker chelsea hat das
papier mit dem tucker sehr gut gelten
das ist eine schreibtischlampe mit der
schreibtischlampe beleuchtet kelsey ihr
gesicht
das ist ein bildschirm michael start auf
den bildschirm
das ist ein aktenschrank im ab
frank befinden sich ganz viele ordner zb
die bilanz 2010 ja nich sagt ich soll
noch mehr akten aufschriften vorlesen
damit ihr wichtige wörter lernt zum
beispiel die bilanz und die bank die
ausgaben die rechnungen die
korrespondenz sehr wichtig dass man alle
korrespondenz aufbewahrt hier michael
ausgaben rechnungen bilanz ausgabe bank
pkw bank ausgaben korrespondenz es
wiederholt sich einiges über die jahre
wie im wirklichen leben
chelsea hat herausgefunden dass das
kalenderblatt geändert werden muss es
ist schon september fällt sie ändert das
kalenderblatt auch sehr wichtig in
unserem büro
bei uns steht in jeder ecke eine gitarre
diese gitarre gehört janisch und er
liebt sie das ist unser briefkasten
michael öffnet dem briefkasten und
schaut nach der post
[Musik]
richtung rechnung rechner
so funktioniert eine schlanke
buchhaltung
das ist ein multifunktionsdrucker damit
kann man drucken faxen und scannen hoch
da kommt gerade ein fax
ich will mehr kaffee hat michael gesagt
michael trinkt gerne kaffee bei der
arbeit
michael wie viele tassen trinkst du pro
tag war vielleicht so 10 oder so sehen
aber nein michael hat seinen kaffee
umgekippt jetzt ist er wütend dach aus
ja das passiert michael öfters ungefähr
einmal pro woche gibt michael seinen
kaffee um
deshalb hat er jetzt eine schicke
schreibtisch unterlage
michael geht jetzt in die küche und holt
einen lappen gleich kommt er wieder
entwischt seinen schreibtisch war immer
weg
das war unser video aus dem büro
während michael seinen schreibtisch
putzt könnt ihr ein bachelor von easy
german werden und uns unterstützen
dann könnt ihr zum beispiel übungen
machen und mehr deutsch lernen hier
könnt ihr ein päckchen werden und hier
könnt ihr easy german abonnieren
tschüss und bis zum nächsten woche
tschüss michael haben wir jetzt
feierabend
aber hallo